foreign
our next question is from Josh
my wife and I are moving and we are
interested in the packing party concept
but the only way we've really seen it is
uh when someone's living in the their
own house and so we're curious any tips
any suggestions or kind of an idea that
you guys have to make it successful when
we're moving into a new place it feels
like the tendency when we move into a
new place is just to unpack everything
and find a home for it and certainly
there's some quality to that but we're
considering not unpacking everything we
just be curious how would you guys go
about doing the packing party concept of
leaving things in the Box until you need
to use them with a new move this is the
perfect opportunity to start over
because moving day is the perfect
opportunity to start over it is a
physical representation of life change
now Ryan we were doing the patreon live
stream earlier and you were talking
about I was 29 years old when I did that
packing party and I was kind of excited
about it but then if I had to do it now
maybe I would feel different and then I
pointed out to you that you've actually
done a bunch of packing parties since
then yeah well you know it's funny I
think that the reason why I have that
like I don't know if I'd want to do it
now is because we have moved so much
Mariah and I've been together 10 times
or 10 years we have moved a total of I
don't know six or seven times and uh
it's yeah it's it is what it is we it
takes us a little bit to find our spot
in a city together but um regardless
I've kind of upgraded the packing party
so I don't know what you would call this
but what we do now is when we pack
things up like we just start like really
questioning every single item because
the initial impulse when you pack up to
move is like just get the boxes open get
everything in there get packed up as
fast as you can where like now we can
kind of curate things as it's going in
and then yes when we get to the new
place we do have a little bit of a
packing party because it does take a
little bit of time to unpack those
things but yeah if you're thinking about
doing a packing party this is the
perfect time to do it Josh yes totally
great idea when you get those boxes in
the new home leave them sealed up and
see what you and your family uh when
your household what items they need and
yeah give yourself three weeks at the
end of those three weeks you get to
decide what you do with the rest of the
stuff in the boxes yeah and that's
exactly how the packing Party Works you
can check out our last film on Netflix
it's called the minimalist lessons now
Ryan walks you through his whole packing
party but that's it you're pretending
that you're moving yeah but if you're
not
pretending you're just moving you're
still doing a packing party and it's
really about slowly unpacking only the
things that add value to your life over
the course of three weeks and then after
those three weeks you let go of anything
that is still sitting in the boxes and
we did this in our last book A lot of
people use things I think we had 52
different individuals and families do
their own version of a packing party and
so you could either do a one-room
packing party so you just like box up my
bathroom's a real big problem area or my
kitchen's a real big problem area and
you unpack only the things you need over
three weeks or you do a multi-room
packing party I really want to tackle
the bathroom and our bedroom or the
closet and the attic or whatever it
might be or if you're really feeling
adventurous get your whole family to do
a whole house packing party you even
cover up the furniture as though it's
inaccessible and then you unpack even
the furniture or your comb or your
toothbrush when you actually need them
and it puts in perspective how many
things we own that we never ever use and
in fact it's probably just getting in
the way absolutely one thing I'll add is
that a change in where you live is often
correlated by a change in how you live
new places open the door for new
possibilities and so you can not only be
intentional with your packing party as
you're putting things into boxes out of
your old place can I live with less but
also as you're taking things out of
boxes in that new space how do those
things resonate with the way you want to
live in this new environment yeah I
think that's important because something
that added value before in a previous
space may be clutter in your new space
we've seen that when we've changed
Studios before and we get more space you
actually sometimes need something
different in that space that feels more
appropriate the thing that felt
appropriate before feels inappropriate
now and if it feels inappropriate that's
a good sign to let go
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free